this morning Time magazine is revealing
its list of the world's 100 most
influential people the magazine created
a special series of covers for the issue
10 time Grammy winner Taylor Swift
two-time Golden Globe winner Sondra o
and the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi our
cover stars they are joined by actor
Dwayne Johnson and soccer superstar
Mohamed Salah and as we already told you
our very own Gayle King was also chosen
to grace a cover she is making the time
100 for the first time only on CBS this
morning Times editor-in-chief and CEO
Eduard Felsen Thal is here good morning
good morning yes it's not even noon and
I'm having a great day yeah we should
have been so humbled by this I can't
even begin to tell you and it means and
I'm not gonna ask you the first question
I'm gonna ask the first question to
Gayle it's not really a question oh so
your date's gonna maybe get better
you've already read this but let's just
read what an Ava Duvernay wrote about
you okay
what most don't understand about Gayle
is that this perfect that is that this
perfected proximity to others is a
superpower that the best journalist
possesses to be present but not centered
to observe to bear witness so the fact
that this year she is being lauded as
one of the all-time great broadcast
interviewers is simply the perfect
signifier a few decades over do what
does it mean to be on the cover but also
to hear those extraordinary words which
those of us who know you feel perfectly
capture you I was so touched to read her
words this is what I don't want to do
[Laughter]
words I actually had to read it twice
and it just made me think again how much
I love this job and I love the people
that I do it with and it was so
unexpected to me and you just have no
idea what this means to me and I was
thinking of my dad who's soul of news
and loved us watching the news and we
had to watch the news and I thought the
news was so damn boring and now here I
am doing the news and being honored this
way by your peers I can't even tell you
I can't even and for Ava to write it
number one they don't tell you who's
writing it so
I found out that was Ava Duvernay who is
a brilliant writer and brilliant
director and what she said I texted her
this one I saw it at like 3 o'clock this
morning and was hoping she was up she
was not say hey but I was so blown away
and so moved by what she had to say
about me she captured I can't even I
can't even tell you what it means and I
just think the picture so pretty I'm
thinking take the picture and she's one
of two journalists that's right here
Apple of journalism and you call her an
unshakable figure in this business why
self well you know the list it's not a
Lifetime Achievement Award it's about
people who shape the year change the
year stood up stood out in Gail's case
continued to sit down that image of
Gail's unshakeable as our Kelly lashed
out I think is seared in the memories of
a lot of people from the last year
coverage of the separation crisis at the
border standing up for the same
transparency here at CBS that that we
all stand up for and our jobs as
journalists you know me this is a
powerful powerful you offer for her we
also have Maria race' on the list Marie
was also one of our person Person of the
Year in 2018 arrested multiple times for
her incredibly courageous coverage of
the Duterte regime in the Philippines
which has lashed back out at her through
the courts that's the finest appearing
so that you do on the list this is what
I LeBron James and Warren Buffett Warren
Buffett writing for LeBron James I
thought was interesting my fight be his
first time yes yes he'll writing crown
yeah well it's a connection with Warren
and LeBron they met on the basketball
court a little over a decade ago it was
a parody so Buffett won
you know they've known each other since
and and LeBron is on the list in large
part because of the amazing success of
the school he started and is in his
hometown and his educational
philanthropy of course in addition to
his skills on the court my favorite this
year one of my favorites this year is
was the late entry we put Tiger Woods
just in my legs right with a wonderful
pairing piece by Justin Timberlake very
moving
Nora Nora this is the most women they've
had on the list most windows ever that
on the list we we have 48 women on the
list this year from 45 last year when we
first started doing this in 2004 I just
went back encounter there were 24 you
know obviously still ways to go in our
society the list is in some ways a
reflection of of our society but amazing
when year for the women on a list
politics and entertainment thank you